thank you all for joining us here I'm
happy to share with you some mischief
that I've been getting into the last six
months I became Dean here about a year
and a half ago and was curious about why
the outcomes in our graduate programs
varied so much in terms of what I was
thinking about in terms of outcomes
included the fraction of students who
finished each degree program the
fraction of students who finished within
six years and then we were also curious
about why students dropped out of some
programs after their third year without
getting a PhD so we measured those
outcome parameters and then I was
curious about why if this might be true
because the students are basically the
same you can't tell any difference among
the students in the various programs
they have the same kind of
qualifications and so on they're all
bright apparently motivated students so
we went looking for a an explanation and
to the survey of the departments and
programs and ask them how they manage
their graduate programs what kind of
support they provided to their students
not financial support because that's the
same across the board but what kind of
academic support how often that they met
with their students and in and what kind
of interactions they had and the
remarkable result of this analysis was
that there is a very strong correlation
between the strength of the academic
support the strength of the mentoring
and the outcomes we have a report that
we published about this in August it's
called improving bridge and education at
Yale and the graphs are way too small
for you to see from the back of the room
but I'll pretend I'm the graph here this
axis i'm going to write the the
intensity of the support by the faculty
on a dis axis the outcomes and the data
are scattered like this but there's a
very strong correlation between good
practices and good outcomes and they
actually sort of fall into two of the
four quadrants a group down in the lower
left-hand quadrant where the
cops aren't so good and support isn't so
good and another group that's up in the
upper right-hand quadrant where the
support is good and the outcomes are
good now the this correlation doesn't
explain all the variables in the system
there are extenuating circumstances some
fields it just takes a little bit longer
and so on but this is actually very good
news because what this tells us is if we
could identify what the good practices
are in managing a graduate program and
if we shared them with everybody and if
I could convince the faculty they
implement all these good mentoring
practices I am confident that the
outcomes would approve so we came to
this conclusion last summer and started
to talk with some of the programs that
we started with the ones that were in
the lower left-hand quadrant that were
struggling and it turned out by simply
sitting down with a chair and the
director of graduate studies in most of
these programs that we actually
accomplished a lot of our goals because
simply by laying out where they stood
and we identified where they were on the
graph to them but not to anybody else
and going through the things that they
might or might not be doing we
identified the sort of a to-do list for
them to improve their programs and by
now we've seen about Oh 45 or 50 of the
graduate programs and virtually everyone
is appreciative of our effort to
identify how they could do better we
also collected a beginning collection of
best practices this is 30 pages of best
practices from across the university and
we found all sorts of fascinating
creative techniques that people were
using to help their graduate students
and of course we shared this and and our
report with all the graduate students
and all the faculty across the
university so everybody has access to
these good ideas our best apartments in
fact our highest performing departments
didn't need any encouragement such as
Peters department
psychology which was really one of our
stellar programs they look through all
the things that we listened that we
wanted them to do they found three
things that they weren't doing how to
faculty meeting and unanimously agreed
to start doing them so this is perfect
now of course I get the people the lower
left-hand quadrant remove quite that
quickly it'll be fabulous okay so that
we have no sticks and no carrots at the
moment because I'm hoping for voluntary
implementation of these these best
practices and I'm hoping that the
students are are going to be my Ally
because it matriculation and every other
chance I have to speak to the students I
point out these things that we expect
the faculty to be doing and ask them to
go back and engage their faculty in the
conversation about how to move forward
now that having been said there's still
some additional needs and the Alumni
Association actually can help us with
with some of these but not all of them
so let me start with a couple internal
ones one is it turns out to my shock
that we have about 500 graduate students
at Yale in humanities departments who
have no place to work on campus they
don't have an office they don't have a
desk make a chair or someplace and don't
ask me how this happened but I'm
determined to find them a place to work
because if they don't have a place to
work they can't develop a community with
their peers and with their faculty and
the provost and the president are
Foursquare behind this effort and it's
going to evolve repurposing some space
so that we could make make that possible
another thing we're working on is to
work with our peer institutions to try
to develop more postdoctoral
opportunities particularly in the
humanities because the job market is
horrible in the humanities these days
and we want to give our students and
students from our peer institutions a
lake up by giving them a little bit more
experience as a postdoc where they can
finish their book and make a bigger mark
in their field we need to help our
students with placement
the faculty tell me that they simply
don't have the expertise to help their
students with placement outside of
academic community personally I find
that rather amazing since a one more
than half of biologists go into
something other than becoming a
professor so we're all used to do that
those sort of outcomes but in the
humanities they say they know how to
help them get into the museum business
or our other lines of work so we're
going to have to help them with that but
this is where the alumni can be helpful
to us one of the things we need to do is
to expand our students horizons so they
think outside of the academic community
into all the wonderful things you can do
with a the training to get in a PhD
program and we've been working with
graduate school alumni association they
see some of my friends here in the front
trying to pops with my ideas about how
to do that we were talking about
internships the idea of this week or
also you know is something simpler than
an internship maybe just an opportunity
to shadow somebody who's running a
museum or are working in private
industry or something like that spend a
week with somebody just to see what the
heck it's all about and we think that
just as a relatively simple exposure to
opportunities outside of the academic
community will help them think about
their futures so that's where that's the
mischief I've been getting into the last
16 months and I'm thrilled that we have
a dozens of serious discussions going on
around campus about how to improve
graduate education thank
i should point out if you're interested
to look at these documents they are
available in the graduate school website